the Las Vegas Senior Softball
Association hitting a home run for many
of its players looking to stay in shape
and also create some friendships Mary
Jane beliesa shares how the love for the
game keeps military veterans connected
out on the field you can feel the
competitiveness of the game
but you can sense the teamwork too
the Las Vegas senior Association plays
softball every week at Lorenzi Park it's
a bond that grew over time not just with
the players but also for the military
veterans looking for an outlet to stay
in shape and connect with the community
Russ Curtis is the field commissioner
for the team he served in the U.S Air
Force from 1965 to 1969. they enjoy it
and a lot of them are pretty Rusty when
they first come out they don't realize
that we're as good as we are you know we
might be you know we we range from 50
years old to 80 years old on this field
Paul Callahan attended the Merchant
Marine Academy and commissioned as an
Ensign in the Navy Callahan says it's
more than just playing a game and the
camaraderie is clear to see these are
our brothers or friends some of us have
lost our spouses we rely on each other
okay I've been on the same travel team
since 2005 and we're real close-knit
knit group and it just means everything
U.S army veteran Mike razorka served two
tours in Vietnam he says the team is
always looking for more players and you
don't have to be a veteran to join I
made a few phone calls and I found out
that they play senior ball here and
being retired I was available so I
found out about this came down and was
immediately put on a on the roster and
I've been playing now for almost nine
years it's not just the guys getting in
all the fun in action but women are too
Rhonda Decker served almost 30 years in
the U.S army she says there are 61
players in the women's league with the
same goal of promoting Health as well as
quality of life and building lifelong
connections win or lose we're all you
know shaking hands in fact we're all
friends and and you know oftentimes
move teams so uh you know it's just
great way to get out like I said get
some exercise
the Las Vegas Senior Softball
Association is open to those 50 years
and older with the oldest player
currently on the league listen to this
87 years old